hey everyone
welcome i am super excited to share with
you
a very important
teacher of mine and
one that is quickly becoming known as
one of the world's strongest
teachers of non-duality and of the
direct
path this is rupert spyra
and this is one of his books the
transparency of things that we'll be
going through together and i have this
great
over the angle over the shoulder angle
and you'll be able to see my most
salient points
that i've drawn out of it and it's
really epic it's just contemplating the
nature of experience
it's very explained like i'm
five and it's very about the direct
experience and rather than
the intellectualization or the
philosophical
so i'm really looking forward to
unpacking this together with you
let's dive in
all right so again the transparency of
things by rupert spyra
contemplating the nature of experience
right here in the book jacket
it immediately jumps you right in
the self contraction gradually
unwinds aka the ego gradually unwinds
and consciousness returns to its natural
condition
it experiences again its own unlimited
nature
this experience is called happiness
and then we have this great quote by
parmenides right in the front that which
is
never ceases to be that which is not
never comes into being parmenidus
all right so this is the perennial
philosophy
the rediscovery of the timeless wisdom
this is the direct path a rigorously
honest investigation into the nature of
awareness
itself
we're looking clearly and simply at
experience itself
our earliest formulations divide
experience into i
and other me and the world
however at a certain stage it begins to
dawn on us that these formulations do
not
express our experience but rather
condition
it
this has been expressed in many
different ways
atman equals brahman i and my father are
one
nirvana equals samsara emptiness is form
i am that consciousness is all there are
not
two things [ __ ] ananda existence
consciousness bliss
it's a knowingness that is beyond the
mind
what is the nature of our experience in
this
moment
and the classic wisdom of your already
it
there's nothing to seek but it remains
for you to recognize
the diamond necklace that is already
around your neck
and we'll be talking about the paper and
screen analogies
that rupert frequently uses
and so right here we dive right into
that analogy about the
paper if you draw your attention to the
white paper on which these words are
written
you experience the uncanny sensation of
suddenly becoming aware of something
that we simultaneously realize is so
obvious
as to require no mention
so this is becoming aware of being aware
of the paper
our awareness of the paper seems to be a
new experience
and we do these we unpack these
analogies in great depth
in our videos on the direct path on our
channel which you can go find
the general idea is that this paper is
the
pure bear empty awareness
that all experience is colored on
and that's the words are the coloration
of experience that's coloring a bear
empty pure i
am-ness that is eternal that is infinite
infinite and its nature is bliss peace
awareness or consciousness is the open
unknowingness on which every experience
is written
i love you rupert you just put it so
perfectly
he's got so many of these great zingers
throughout here
it is only this open unknowingness
the source the substance and the destiny
of all experience
that is indicated here over and over
and over again
so in many ways this is like an
involution
we relax
into bare empty pure
awareness
and the breath helps us relax
our awareness
it's more like this and less like
like that
in many ways the involution is like the
absolute it's like the self-realization
and then there's the spectrum
of where on the evolution it's expressed
as an unhealthy ego versus a healthy
self-actualization
and the proper way to attain a healthy
self-actualization
is via self-realization first
so you must come over here and this is
why rahman and maharshi said that the
best thing that you can do
for the world is to become self-realized
so you ebb all the way over here first
and then naturally you
act as a divine channel of
god into the highest morality of
self-realization
sensing in turn is discovered to be made
of knowing
and if we explore knowing we find that
it is made of consciousness
if we explore i we find it is made of
abstract concepts of the mind collapse
here
again involution
within itself
and then evolution gives birth to a mind
a body
and a world this process
of evolution and involution is the dance
of the oneness
so eloquent
and we also dived into this in our last
review of the universal one by walter
russell as well
that that oceanic-ness it dances
with its creations of waves
it takes shape and dissolves every
nuance of experience
mind attempts to describe the
modulations of this emptiness
manifesting itself as the fullness of
experience
in this fullness recognizing itself as
emptiness
knowing all the time that in doing so it
is holding a candle to the wind
so every single time that we attempt
to have the ocean describe the waves
and every time that the waves describe
the ocean
that's ultimately what the ebb and flow
of this
is and it does
feel like it's holding a candle to the
wind as we aim to
describe this but the metaphors
themselves are very powerful
and they can explain like i'm five
succinctly describe
what the nature of our reality is and in
that sense it's
revealed mind is being used to create
evocations rather than descriptions of
the experience of consciousness knowing
itself
these evocations are temporary
expressions like
flowers blossoming for a moment shedding
the perfume of their origin on the
garden
of unknowing
there is simply the clear seeing of the
true nature of this current experience
we allow the naked clarity of experience
itself to relieve itself of the burden
of duality
separation is not simply understood to
be an illusion
it is felt as such
they die of the fierce clarity of being
clearly
seen
its nature is always only pure
consciousness
rupert's got great analogies that are
coming up
the sugar cube one for the ego
dissolving is so good
oh man all right it is precisely the
idea that the body and the world
exist as objects in time and space
independent and separate from
consciousness
that is intellectual and abstract it is
not based on experience
the experience of the appearance of the
body
in the world takes place simultaneously
with the experience of consciousness
knowing itself
it is the same experience one
experience
everything that is known is known
through consciousness
it's this is-ness this being or
existence
the very i am-ness
it is the exposure of our false
certainties
and they amount to a religion
of materialism
it's so important to expose these false
certainties
and that's what rupert is doing
throughout this book is exposing those
pointing to the perennial philosophy
from many different sides of the
mountain
we never experience anything outside
experience
all experience takes place here and now
so the nature of reality whatever that
is must be present
in the intimacy and immediacy of this
current
experience consciousness of something
and there is the existence of that
something
consciousness has veiled itself from
itself
and we unpack that also in the
the seven densities of consciousness the
law of
one video where we talked about how cool
it is
that we have the capacity to create this
veil of forgetting and then pierce it
and then
self-realize it's the most fascinating
aspect
to our nature
mind collapses from within
and this is the sugar cube it's so good
all right
there is only one single seamless
totality that
consciousness and existence are one that
there is only
one reality
consciousness veils itself from itself
by pretending to limit itself to a
separate entity
and then forgets that it is pretending
beautiful
it is simply to see what clearly is our
beliefs are the root cause of
psychological suffering and they are
dismantled by a process of contemplative
investigation
assumptions we could deconstruct these
assumptions
this understanding is beyond the mind
consciousness experiences itself
directly and knowingly
understanding is not created by a
process in the mind any more than
blue sky is created by clearing in the
clouds
however it may be revealed by the mind
again not created but revealed
very similarly to the clouds
clearing and then the blue sky being
revealed
that i am-ness
the timeless moment in which
consciousness is revealed to itself
and that is the diamond necklace that is
already around your neck
like rumi said being finally recognized
which is called
god or self-realization or the
yoga and
vipassana is seeing reality as it is a
very important style of theravada
buddhism
where you go through the process of
training
that capacity again the blue sky isn't
created by clearing clouds it's always
there your i
am-ness your is-ness that eternal
infinite bliss and peace of awareness
that is being colored by experience
is always there that sky is always there
we're just mistaking the clouds and the
modulations and we're
encountering deep psychological
suffering as an egoic
entity of being separate
and we we have another analogy that's
coming from rupert we slowly
release our clenched fist
sense perception occurs or appears
in consciousness
the substance of perceiving and sensing
is none other than the consciousness in
which it appears
the mind the body and the world are
located inside consciousness
and are made only out of consciousness
that is our experience
and again for those that are wondering
you know the reason why
we're doing these unpackings
of some of our most influential
influences we're doing it this way where
we
undergo the exegesis the drawing out of
the most salient things
ourselves and then we bring them onto
camera and show them to you this way
is because that way you get a direct
influence of the actual
writer the author themselves you know
you get
rupert's writings directly it's not just
our exegesis that you see
but you literally see the fact that
they wrote this themselves and that you
can then pause the video throughout
and take notes yourself so keep drawing
out what is most salient as we're going
and then also you can find the links in
the bio below to
rupert's his website
where he has videos of his non-dual
teachings and much else but also his
book link is below
and you can actually get the
transparency of things
yourself and then have undergo this
similar process
of exegesis so drawing out what is most
salient
so as you need pause the video take
notes revisit the content
draw out what is most salient for you
it is impossible to experience a limit
to consciousness
because such a limit would by definition
have some
objective quality
we have no actual experience of a limit
to consciousness
why do we think
that we consciousness are a personal
entity inside the body
there is no experiential evidence to
validate the belief that consciousness
in which the mind the body and the world
appear is limited or personal
we have no experience of a limited or
personal consciousness
again this is the i am-ness of the sky
that is being obscured by the
clouds
were contracted into a separate egoic
entity
and were like a clenched fist
piercing the veil to sell for god
realization
everywhere
is in consciousness
whatever is known is known by and
through consciousness it knows
all that it is known whatever
appears emerges out of is sustained by
and is dissolved into consciousness
beyond consciousness i am-ness is
formless absolute which is not an
experience
and that's a something that we've
covered in our direct path
teachings which is a more advanced state
of self-realization which is
the attributeless
agentless formless absolute
which is beyond that experiencer
and experiencing of the i
am-ness of the consciousness sky
the experience of consciousness
recognizing itself
remembering itself there is no evidence
in our experience to suggest that we
have different consciousnesses or indeed
that there is more than one
consciousness
i love it there is only one
consciousness
everything falls into place
have only ever been experiencing our own
unlimited self
again even from a scientific angle
we have to take this from the
perspective of things like
the sir roger penrose
and the cutting edge of physics winning
the nobel prize
in physics in 2020 believing in uh
cyclic cosmology
and so you have to understand that all
coming from the same source you know
that's why
that's why lao tzu was so influential in
saying that wisdom
is knowing your source if you know your
source you recognize the oneness of
being meaning that this consciousness
this awareness itself
is shared again that's why the graphic
in chapter nine of high level perception
on consciousness is
all about seeing the planet like a big
brain with nerve endings and that every
single one of us
if you look at the pupil that pupil that
blackness
is god that is being shared and then
that little iris
around the pupil is the unique
experience or expression that we have of
that
infinity that is being colored by
experience
we unpack this more in our other videos
to check out on our channel like the
god's brain video
is a good one to check out on this topic
and this is the yoga sutras of patanjali
you know 2 000 years ago we have all
these beautiful perennial wisdoms that
are being highlighted by us
but that have been lost in modernity so
that it's super important for us to
bring them back
here yogas
means yoga equals stop modulating
awareness
yoga means union in sanskrit union
equals
consciousness waves quieting
this is identical to deep sleep again
when your thought stops when your
consciousness waves quiet
what is left is a non-modulated a
non-colored
awareness and you recognize that that
awareness
is eternal that its nature is bliss and
peace and that it's being
colored by experience by thought by
emotion by feeling
by belief by objects
and we'll have many other
explorations of that deep sleep
throughout as well rupert does a great
job bringing that in
all perception takes place in
consciousness
we are abiding as we are
of that i consciousness just
am
attention is drawn to the presence of
the knower
suddenly seems to become more present
it shines the nowhere
again this is a theme that we talk about
so much
on the show you are it however it
remains for you to recognize
it and this means embodied non-duality
you can't just be an egoic separate self
and say that oh okay
i get it i'm already it it doesn't work
that way
you have to actually pierce the veil and
self-realize
consciousness is naturally returning to
itself
becoming aware of itself it
just seems to forget itself from time to
time it seems to ignore itself
that's the beauty of these creation
designs i love it
when consciousness looks for itself it
merges with
itself it is revealed to itself and this
revelation
is the dissolution of the question it is
this
knowingness beyond the mind that is the
true
answer to all questions about the nature
of experience
love it the i cannot see itself
the process of discovering that it
always already knows itself
so as the mind tries to turn itself
towards consciousness
it dissolves it's fascinating
i love this sugar cube analogy this is
gonna be so good oh man
okay it is pure knowingness
the seeking thought reveals
consciousness
when you investigate the nature of
reality
you land on consciousness and not
a symbol
all right here we go god i love this
analogy
okay this is the seeking sugar cube
analogy all right
the seeking thought is like a sugar cube
looking for consciousness is like
putting the sugar cube in a cup of tea
the tea dissolves the sugar cube
likewise consciousness dissolves the
seeking thought
it's so beautiful so
in essence this sugar cube analogy is so
profound because
it's basically saying that the
egoic separate self as it goes
the process of seeking the diamond
necklace that's already around its neck
that it as it pierces the veil and
as self-realization god realization
happens
what occurs is that it's just like a
sugar cube dissolving in the cup of tea
the mind the egoic self the separate
entity dissolves it's beautiful
and you're just left with that infinite
consciousness
that is eternally being colored by
experience
it's so gorgeous it's such a beautiful
analogy rupert
you know that's another part of rupert
you know in our interview with rupert
which if you haven't seen i highly
recommend checking out our interview
featuring rupert
that his metaphors
are so strong and the metaphors are very
explained like i'm five and they
dive you right into the nature of
experience very simply
the best teachers do that
consciousness knowing itself returning
to itself knowingly
okay again throughout this we're just
going to be pointing to the same
perennial spiritual wisdom from many
different
ways up that mountain for many faces so
again we're going to point to this again
here
meditation is the cessation
the stopping of the monkey mind clouds
to remember i am the sky
again yogas chitta vritti nirodha
again relax your contracted fist this is
the contracted fist
of the egoic separate self
relax into your pure
bear empty awareness pre-coloration
and recognize that that is the i am-ness
of the sky
and that from that point of
self-realization then
every single cloud of experience that
you encounter
you will shine through
that bliss in peace
that is inherent in consciousness
knowing itself
meditation is not an activity it is the
cessation
of an activity
stop the thinking mind and recognize
stop the monkey mind and recognize the
sky
i want i don't want our contractions
we throw a veil over itself
the separate entity is something we
as consciousness do it is not something
we
are again we're playing a big
game with the veil
and the separate entity it's not
something we are it's something we do
it's a game we play
and then we pierce that think of all
eight billion people piercing the veil
in their own different ways right now
and that is what is meant by the sufi
metaphysic
the unity of all finding and you can
watch our video on that topic too it's
fascinating it was one of my
profound satori sudden enlightenment
that happened along my journey
to non-duality
embedded within every experience is the
taste of its own eternity
as a man is so he sees as william blake
said
as consciousness sees itself so the
world
appears exactly
once the doors of perception are
cleansed
we will see ourselves as infinite
and that's william blake and aldous
huxley
consciousness memory of itself is always
deeper than its forgetting
the desire to return to itself to abide
in itself
can never be extinguished
i am no longer this open free unlimited
consciousness rather i am this
limited fragment that i have just
created within myself
i am a body so in many ways it goes like
a child like infinity
subscribes to all of the matrix
nonsense that turns it into a corporate
adult that has an egoic separate self
and that is then undergoes a process of
piercing the veil and self realizing its
child like
infinity again
and we put many of these highlights
like this one meditation equals the
liberation from
separation we put these core highlights
also
in the bio as well for you to check out
so you can directly go there for key
insights and notes
and then repurpose those for your own
enrichment and piercing of the veil to
self-realization
meditation is simply the liberation from
the burden of separation
and this is a good highlight actually of
what i'm talking about so rather than
just seeing the review of
me saying this now you actually get to
see
rupert having written the
exact same words
and so this is what i'm trying to share
with you as we do these
styles of reviews of the exegesis the
drawing out of salience from
our main influences works is that you
get to see
this and this is a main important piece
for you to to see why we're doing this
so you can see this
and so that you yourself can then draw
out many of these
core insights as well
and also get excited about you know
getting more of rupert's content
across his youtube channel that's
blowing up and also
his different books and going and
actually buying them yourself and going
through this process of
atamovitra self-inquiry self-realization
inquiry into the nature of your own
experience
very simply experientially
consciousness becomes more and more
accustomed to remaining in itself
as itself that's what's meant by abiding
the impulse to contract into the
separate entity is progressively
undermined consciousness stays at home
and this is what i'm sharing across all
these direct path videos with you guys
as well
throughout my journey especially in even
just the last couple of
weeks of becoming
more and more of that light instead of
just flickering is now staying on
and it means that my allen sakyan is
completely dissolved
atlas is basically completely dissolved
all that's left is just
non-dual awareness of bliss and peace
eternally being colored
and that is what is meant by
enlightenment
and everyone deserves to pierce that
veil and self-realize and experience
bliss and peace 24 7 rather than
for five minutes a day consciousness
shines
in every experience
meditation is what we are and the person
is something that we do
from time to time love it rupert
all right
consciousness is impersonal and
unlimited
so consciousness is one and infinite
in the analogy of the ocean the waves
are a metaphor for the appearances that
arise
upon or within the ocean of
consciousness
so the form is the wave
and the content is the water
again this is probably one of the most
important perennial
analogies the oceanic
of infinite consciousness and the
different creative
forms and expressions as waves
that are composed of water of
consciousness
so consciousness modulates
manifestations
and that's what we see here with this
creativity of
a reality that we're in
this is such a good way to say it the
ego
is consciousness pretending to be a
separate entity
it's a perfect way to put it rupert
hopefully this is very enriching for you
all
as well in your journeys
suffering is already a rejection
of the current situation a lack of
acceptance of the current situation
as it is
and this is why people like bentino
massaro who have been another massive
influence
on me have focused on the phrase accept
yourself
love yourself and become the creator
and that's a really simple way to put it
accept
the current situation as it is there is
no lack
everything is perfect
there is no disharmony it's all perfect
who are you
you know as david hawkins says who are
you
to be angry at reality
to be angry at the entirety of the
evolutionary experience
that you're having an experience that is
not according to
the creative expression that it is
so that's a core insight is to have no
lack
have perfection for the current
situation as it is accept yourself love
yourself become the creator
don't create that suffering would be
with rejecting
the current situation
simply accept the current situation
itself
suffering with c's right there
you're already diamond yet it remains
for you to recognize it
and another one of our favorite
analogies the screen analogy
so the screen is the support and the
substance of the players
it's absurd to think that the screen and
the players are separate or different
from one another
the players depend on the screen but the
screen does not depend on the players
consciousness is not just their support
but also their substance
it's apparent independence and
separation from consciousness
that is illusory
the analogy of the screen they're all
around you
and just use your device
to just lock the screen
and just see it for
it without any modulation without any
coloration
that is the pure bare empty awareness
that we're talking about that is eternal
infinite in its nature's bliss and peace
and it's being colored
the screen's being colored by all of the
different
modulations and expressions
the waves of that oceanicness
appearance is simply a modulation of
this knowingness
this is what consciousness is it is pure
experiencing
again it sometimes just takes time with
that screen that's locked just sit there
and just look at the screen in a
contemplative way
before it's colored and then see your
consciousness and awareness similarly
before it's colored by experience
that juxtaposition is really important
to understand
this although as we say in our direct
path videos that that juxtaposition
is ultimately transcended because it's
all one but we create the dual
separation
for people to be able to see what we're
talking about
experiencing this and knowingness are
synonyms for
consciousness
so we do not do anything to the feelings
in fact we stop doing something to them
we stop investing
them with the power to veil reality
desires continue to arise but their
purpose is no longer the avoidance of
feeling
nor the attainment of happiness their
purpose is to
express happiness their purpose in fact
their nature is to manifest share
and celebrate happiness
we'll have some further explanations of
that that are really insightful
so we abide as this witnessing
consciousness
knowingly and that's why people like
osho
are also so adamant about that
witnessing consciousness
another great teacher to go check out
our true body is consciousness
what is our actual experience of the
boundary between what is
inside ourself and what is outside our
self
there is no experience of such a
boundary
and that's why perforation and porosity
are massive keys which we talk about in
chapter nine in high level perception on
consciousness
where we showcase the difference between
somebody that has perforated
and porous where they are understanding
and accepting at a deep level of the
porosity of themselves with the o2 and
co2 exchange that's constantly happening
20 000 times a day with their breath and
the photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees on the planet
or with them drinking water that's part
of the same hydrological cycle that was
here
66 million years ago when dinosaurs were
here and similarly with their gut
microbiome and the symbiosis there
there's no way to create a boundary of
separation between
you and the outside world and so
that's very important because the egoic
self
that's contracted itself is with like a
box
around their head thinking they're just
a separate entity
again perforation porosity are key
why do we think that the sensation we
call our hand
is closer to us than the sound in the
distance is that our actual experience
each appearance each appears at the same
zero distance from consciousness
great way to put it
consciousness is not simply the witness
but also the substance of every object
that appears
within it every object is made out of
consciousness
it is an expression of consciousness
objects as appearing to consciousness
in consciousness as consciousness
consciousness reabsorbs the body the
mind and the world
into itself
it realizes itself as everything this
condition could be called
love realizes itself to be the very
substance of everything
consciousness knows itself as everything
everything is included within itself
and is an expression of itself
there is only consciousness there is
only being which simultaneously creates
witnesses expresses and experiences
itself
in every experience we have
love that all right
and this is what we said in our first
direct path video
simply the fact that there is something
that there
is being that there is consciousness is
the most
extraordinary thing if you're not in
absolute awe on a moment-to-moment basis
that you exist in that consciousness and
awareness
are experiencing a reality if that in
itself
does not may bring you tremendous awe
investigate why it does not and that is
the process of self-inquiry and
self-realization and inevitably
that egoic sense of separate self will
dissolve as the sugar cube in the cup
of tea walking on water or teleporting
through space is no more remarkable than
a speck of dust or the fly
that has just landed on this table and
that's why similarly
people like terence mckenna when they
were
told about not having that much time
left to live that
everything became filled with awe even a
blade of grass
or a little bug that was walking along
the ground
became beautiful
and so to have that child-like aw
is the nature of our
being
it's a yoga of wonder astonishment and
delight
we simply stand open empty silent
unknowing and wondering
we dance with the question for a while
and then merge with it returning to its
source
silence the real response is silence
itself and that's why people like
sri ramana maharshi were silent
a lot when asked question
and that led to a lot of incredible
self-realizations
for people knowing and being
are identical when referring to
consciousness
and this is something that i'm
undergoing right now too is
simultaneously balancing my
my interviewer and content creator
angle with an angle of
silence and
being the pure bear empty awareness of
the sky
and then practicing that
formless agentless attributeless
absolute and that requires a lot of
silence
and we have to become more and more
comfortable with silence
in order to self-realize
consciousness and existence are one and
the same
that is our moment by moment experience
the mind and the senses are like a prism
through which
the oneness of the consciousness
existence appears to be refracted into
ten thousand things
it is the separation between the
existence of the world and the presence
of consciousness that is illusory
it is the creativity of consciousness
through the faculties of mind
and senses which refracts oneness into a
dance of apparent multiplicity
remove time and space from experience
remove
name and form and we are left with the
oneness of consciousness
existence timeless spaceless presence
being
the mind and senses are double agents
they work for both ignorance and
understanding this realization is the
moment the prodigal son
returns turns around and proceeds back
towards the father on exactly the same
path that he originally took on his
flight away from him
and this is a really important biblical
story and it has a lot to do with this
direct path of the egoic
separate entity like the prodigal son
turning back around
and piercing the veil and understanding
that consciousness is
it this is also the moment at which the
traditional spiritual path of
renunciation becomes the tantric path
of embrace and inclusion so again we're
not trying to just say that
that is maya illusion
renunce it rather we have a tantric path
of weaving
so we weave our self-realizations with
the social fabric
it is the moment at which the full
spectrum of experience is welcomed
explored and celebrated for what it
truly is
it is the transition from i am nothing
to i am everything
from the path of discrimination to the
path of love it is the moment when the
emptiness of consciousness recognizes
itself
as the fullness of experience
the mind the body and the world are
understood to be expressions of
consciousness rather than distractions
from it
there is one condition one ever present
condition
which we call i consciousness presence
in which
all apparent states come and go the
ocean
of all the waves
deep sleep is in fact simply the
presence of consciousness shining by
itself that is why it is so peaceful and
enjoyable
there is no time in deep sleep
lots of people come on our program and
talk about
how much they enjoy deep sleep
so we're going to unpack that throughout
a lot more
consciousness takes the shape of every
appearance although
it itself is shapeless just as
water takes the shape of a wave although
it is itself
shapeless
deep sleep is peace deep sleep is the
presence of consciousness without
objectivity peace is inherent in
consciousness
that peace and consciousness are one
so that same peace
that you experience in deep sleep when
consciousness is not experiencing the
modulations and colorations of
objects thoughts feelings emotions and
beliefs
is very similar to what
we talk about as inherent in the sky
or the ocean of consciousness even in
the waking state
so in many ways the waking state to
practice
being the sky or the ocean in the waking
state
is kind of what meditation does which is
basically what is felt during deep sleep
don't be lost in the waves and the
clouds
recognize yourself as the sky and the
ocean
that's the first step self-realization
and then you can self-actualize
beautifully with
a more true experience where you shine
through all of the coloration and
modulation of the sky
and the
sorry of the clouds and of the waves
everything is ultimately an expression
of consciousness
so ultimately is everything an
expression of peace
every experience is the shape of silence
silence is pure in and of itself
a very important teaching by sri
aurobindo
and the mother mural faucet to us as
well
so repeatedly shatter the illusion of
separation
the first thing upon awakening in the
morning
practice i am infinite consciousness
i've been doing that a lot in the
morning at night throughout the day
just basically re-baselining to the
light permanently staying on rather than
flickering so basically
spending zero percent of the day in ego
separate self and that's how it
dissolves
as we wake in the morning the piece of
deep sleep still pervades our experience
before the appearance of separation has
become fully established
consciousness immediately loses itself
in identification with a fragment
it condenses itself into a body mind and
the world
is correspondingly projected outside
the illusion of separation reappears one
pretends to be two
the contracted me becomes a seeker
consciousness pretending to be a
separate entity
meditation is sometimes described as
sleeping while we are awake
we take the same attitude towards
objects
that we take in our sleep no attitude at
all
we simply abide as we are
self-realization
gives you inner bliss peace eternity so
all downstream wu way or effortless
action
is for the highest and that comes from
lao tzu and the dao to ching highly
recommend reading that as well if you
haven't
so basically self-realization gives you
the inner bliss peace eternity
so everything that happens downstream in
that self-actualization is like
effortless action will way
for the absolute highest
that's why that's the first thing is
self-realization
god realization happiness is the
experience of consciousness knowing
itself knowingly
it is happiness itself that seeks itself
oh this is great i knew we'd get here
this is part we were talking about
earlier
desire is liberated from the requirement
to produce
happiness
desire as such is experienced as energy
as
life it is already its own fulfillment
so aka today's
desire ego is enslaved to produce
happiness
self-realization pierces the veil
revealing our inherent
nature as bliss peace liberating desire
from the requirement to produce
happiness enabling its own fulfillment
experienced as energy
as life gosh love that
we are in modernity so obsessed
once i accomplish this it's seeking the
trophy once i accomplish this then i'll
be happy
so happiness is tied to this desire of
the trophy
of the rewards when in reality the 24
7 bliss peace nature of consciousness is
happiness
and it's on a journey and every moment
in the journey
is the destination the waves of the
oceanic infinity
is the creative expression it is the
destination
i love that quote by dan eldon the
journey is the destination
the separate entity has no freedom but
as there is no separate entity why
mention it
as consciousness have absolute freedom
we are absolute freedom
if all the minds bodies and worlds that
exist
are interconnected in one seamless
system how could consciousness which is
considered in scientific materialism to
be a byproduct of the system itself be
individual and separate
everything arises spontaneously out of
consciousness
and that consciousness is therefore its
sole and ultimate
cause
all right we'll read this and then i'll
read the top part here
when an object appears it appears as a
modulation
of consciousness consciousness is
simultaneously the substance and the
witness
of whatever appears
so again there is only consciousness
taking the shape
of our experience from moment to moment
and that's why up here we wrote
modulation
of love-like consciousness it's a
rhythmic
balanced interchange which is very
aligned with walter russell
and the universal one so a rhythmic
balanced interchange
is the modulation it is the waves it is
the creative expression
of the oceanic infinitude of love light
consciousness
consciousness is one with the totality
of every experience not just
with a fragment the body mind it comes
to know
itself as the witness of all objects
before re-engaging with the totality of
its experience and recognizing itself as
everything
this part's really interesting
so the idea of
i am everything is very much like
advaita vedanta where the atman and the
brahman
are the same that's kind of the nondual
infinite consciousness and then the idea
of
the more buddhist idea of no self
is more like the absolute the formless
the agentless the attributeless
and that's the i am nothing which is so
fascinating
check out our direct path videos for
more about that
so i am not only the body
deep sleep is simply another name for
this timeless
spaceless presence
happiness and the separate entity are
mutually exclusive positions
i love that one rubert uh that one was
that one was so good that i had to post
it right away
onto our
instagram it was so good
happiness and the separate entity are
mutually exclusive positions
consciousness begins to tire exhausted
consciousness pretending to be a
separate entity
spiritual search recognition that
consciousness is happiness
fulfillment or peace itself always and
already prior to and within
every experience
natural relaxation of the identification
consciousness becomes increasingly
comfortable abiding
in and as itself the ease of being
begins to pervade experience
relax the clenched fist
sink into the oceanic-ness
use the breath
the experience of love is precisely this
relaxation of consciousness
is exclusive identification with a
separate body mind
and as a result the inevitable inclusion
of the other
of all others within itself
very much like king pretending to be an
ordinary person
the king reclaims his royal identity
that he realizes that although he
thought
felt and behaved as though he were bound
in fact he was always free
he realizes that his status as an
ordinary person was self-imposed and
imaginary
realize yourself as the king as the
queen
the sun's nature is to illumine
likewise consciousness is self-luminous
mind is form
the prodigal son leaves the palace he
turns away from the father towards the
world of objects
consciousness throws a veil over itself
and the search for itself begins every
now and then the search is brought to an
end in a moment of understanding love or
beauty
consciousness is reminded of itself
consciousness reminds itself
of itself it tastes itself
those are those light flickerings that
occur
it's tasting the true nature of reality
pierce the veil permanently keep that
light on
enlightenment
we experience only one thing
consciousness and reality are one
suffering is another name for this
misinterpretation
it is a seamless experience it is one
experience
as soon as it's fragmented into an
entity
that is separate and egoic that's where
the root of psychological suffering
is that's the game we play
is this new sensation that is generated
by our hand touching the table
two sensations no it is one
again put your hand on something is that
new sensation
generated by your hand touching that
something
two no it's one
it is not possible to draw a clear line
between the body and the world
this is clearly seen if we ask ourselves
whether sensation a the hand slash table
is on the inside the me side or the
outside
the other side of the boundary so when
you put your hand on that something
is that sensation of the hand touching
the book happening inside you or outside
you
you just can't draw the boundary
it's very simple explorations into
non-duality
we are thus left with one thing the
seamless totality of experience before
it is conceptualized into ten thousand
things
again that
one experience of witnessing
consciousness
rather than ten thousand things
this witnessing consciousness throughout
the totality
of experience
every objective experience is a seamless
whole
consciousness object
this is the return of the prodigal son
the moment of looking back towards the
father is the moment of recognizing that
consciousness is present
consciousness loses itself in the world
of objects the moment it turns its
attention away from
objects and towards itself it recognizes
itself
as it turns its attention more and more
towards itself it becomes absorbed in
itself
the father knows that the sun never
leaves the kingdom but the sun
that is conscious is believing itself to
be an object has forgotten this
and so he has to return in reality the
sun is reclaimed
and this is what is illustrated by our
again the graphic in the chapter 9
on consciousness is with the iceberg is
that
you can't be at those surface level
waves of
the iceberg where you're you're only
focused on
objects once you turn
inquiry inward into that self-inquiry
that atma vitra the self-realization god
realization
opens up you pierce the veil but again
if you're
only folk that's the depth of the
iceberg but if you're only focused at
the surface level
you're going to continuously occur
the psychological suffering of the egoic
separate entity
we end with the understanding that
consciousness is the ever
present reality of all things and that
everything appears within it
and as an expression of it consciousness
witnesses and expresses itself
simultaneously
in every experience and that that
is what we are always changing always
the same
love it you know that's the paradoxes
they're beautiful
and it's not even a paradox this is
transcended by true
knowingness which is you are the ocean
the infinite you are also the waves
the creative expressions modulations
our experience has always only
consciousness
consciousness ceases to veil itself from
itself
with erroneous ideas it ceases to veil
itself with its own creativity
that's a funny playful way to look at it
is that we're
veiling ourselves with our own playful
creativity as these egoic separate
entities that then
pierce the veil and self-realize
when consciousness relieves itself of
the belief and feeling that it is the
body-mind it simultaneously relieves
itself
of the belief and the feeling that it is
not
the world
love is the natural condition of
consciousness when it is knowingly
one with all things it includes all
things within itself and is itself the
substance of all things
we experience a beginning and an end to
all objects but we never
experience a beginning or an end to
consciousness to ourself
sentience disappears on death but not
that consciousness disappears
nobody falls asleep and nobody wakes up
deep sleep is timeless presence
only now is experienced all experience
is now
and now is ever present eternity now
is experienced simply as it is timeless
presence
the now is the substance and container
of all experience again
the now is the substance and container
of all experience
that's why eckhart tolle the power of
now
the substance and container of all
experience
enjoy that bliss peace harmony
perfection no lack
in the now baseline yourself to that
that's our true nature every time
consciousness ceases to take the shape
of the mind the body and the world it
knows itself again as presence or being
presence prior to time and space that
remains
attention be given to these gaps between
perceptions that's a teaching of
non-duality that is sometimes suggested
to help people
understand that presence
attention is consciousness with an
object when the object vanishes
attention simply remains
what it always is consciousness it
witnesses and manifests
itself simultaneously as that object
it recognizes itself
being is both behind and within
appearances
the being that shines in all experience
is known in our self as the experience i
am in the world it is known as it
is we share the presence that we are
with all things
consciousness is the primary and most
intimate fact of experience
meditation is simply to abide knowingly
as this presence of consciousness
we just remain there knowingly we abide
there
in time the first layer of resistance
that i don't like
dies down
peace and happiness are inherent
qualities of
this presence
[Music]
a little bit of rearranging heat
wow
okay
draw attention to the presence and
primary of primacy of consciousness
not only is consciousness present in
every experience
but that it is our primary experience
thought obviously occurs within
consciousness
our experience is one seamless totality
consciousness and the thought
sensation or perception are one
experience
it is consciousness that contains the
mind the body and the world on
equal footing the mind the body and the
world appear in
consciousness the old belief that the
world contains the body which contains
the mind which contains consciousness
triggers a series of thoughts feelings
and activities
all based on that belief
objects do not just appear in
consciousness they appear as
consciousness
consciousness does not just witness
every experience
it expresses itself as every experience
everything that is experienced is
experienced by through
in and as consciousness consciousness
witnesses
experiences and expresses itself from
moment to moment
and when there are no objects present it
simply
remains as it always is
that is all there is presence
this
our art must give us a taste of her
eternity
time and space themselves turn out
to be nothing other than the very
thought with which they are
conceived
nature and man are part of one
integrated system and must therefore
share their existence their being must
be shared
and this is actually
i'll read the top in a moment after this
existence or beingness
which is always present and yet does not
appear
eternity
it is only reality that is ever actually
experienced
and this is what i talked about with
rupert for a little bit in our interview
was
his teacher francis lucille whose
uh teacher was jean klein and then
um krishna menon
was that's the lineage and that
there's a beautiful quote from francis
lucille
which is that the nature of reality
is an eternal 4th of july
fireworks celebration
such a perfect way to put it
the nature of reality is an eternal 4th
of july
fireworks celebration so the more that
you
have self realized the oceanic
infinitude
and then realized that it's expressed as
the waves of creative expression
the more that you see those as fireworks
that are eternal
in the ultimate analysis there is no
difference between the two states of
dreaming and waking
reality is the substance of every
experience it is the existence
the beingness the is-ness the suchness
the knowingness
the experiencingness in every experience
boom this formless reality is concealed
or revealed by appearances depending on
how we see
what is it in our experience that is
undeniably and continuously present
and yet has no external qualities
consciousness is undeniably experienced
during any appearance and yet it has no
objective qualities
consciousness and reality or existence
are both present in every experience
they are one consciousness existence
consciousness and existence are one
i and my father are one
i and my father are one is an expression
of the fundamental unity of
consciousness and reality of the self
with all things john 10 30
i and my father are one
again similarly here
as we've been mentioning it's like
creative modulations on an infinite
mirror
or creative waves on an infinite ocean
consciousness takes the shape of the
perception but remains itself
just as a mirror takes on the appearance
of an object
and yet always remains exactly as it is
so consciousness and reality are ever
present
always now they are eternal the purpose
of
art as giving us a taste of this
eternity
i love that
william blake every bird
that cuts the airy way is an immense
world of delight enclosed by the five
senses
in cezanne
the reality of nature which she calls
her
eternity is experienced as a thrill
and they both suggest that inherent in
the oneness of consciousness and reality
is the experience of delight that the
experience
is thrilling
so again the nature is the eternal
fireworks
it's the eternal thrill the eternal
delight
sachit ananda consciousness bliss
consciousness and reality are one that
there is no
separation between i and other between
me and you between me and the world
between
[ __ ] and sat the experience of this
realization is known in india as anando
which has traditionally been translated
as bliss
anandas perhaps better translated as
peace or happiness or simply fulfillment
the absence of agitation or the ease of
being whereas the egoic separate entity
is disease not
ease of being
imagine the modern health care
industrial complex
taking on that definition of dis
ease so self-realization is the number
one thing that the
medical industrial complex should be
prioritizing but how many of our
physicians are trained
on that in school let's prioritize that
next generation architectures let's do
it
consciousness and reality are realized
to be one
their inherent unity is revealed peace
or
happiness is another name for that
experience it is very
natural
the sacred works of art shine with the
presence of this understanding and
therefore have the power to convey or
communicate it directly they evoke it
classical greece this experience was
described as beauty
the experience of recognizing that
consciousness and reality are one
consciousness
is recognizing itself consciousness is
remembering its own reality its own
being
it looks in the mirror of experience and
sees itself it experiences its own
reality
such works of art give us the taste of
eternity
and this is again very similar to
robert pearsig's work on the metaphysics
of quality
moq if you haven't read zen in the art
of motorcycle maintenance it's fantastic
and again it's very much like an eternal
art show all of the
oceanic waves are an eternal art show of
modulations and creativity
embody that the non-duality
of the oceanic-ness expressing itself
creatively and eternally as modulations
of waves that is your key
to 24 7 bliss peace enlightenment
self-realization god realization
consciousness is that knowingness this
knowing is the illuminating quality
in all experience the knowingness of
consciousness is that which
illumines all experience consciousness
is self-luminous
consciousness is one with itself and
with all things
i am that i am exodus
3 14.
when an object appears it is
consciousness that takes the shape of
that object
consciousness knows an object by being
that object
an object derives its being from
consciousness from
amnesty being is present in every
experience
consciousness is that being in the
knowledge that i
am consciousness and being are one
when this is known the mind the body and
the world
become transparent and luminous they
shine with presence
as presence
the i am becomes i am that in the
presence of appearances
consciousness gives its amnes to all
things the amnesty of self
is the is-ness of things consciousness
is one
with all appearances consciousness knows
itself as all appearances
there is oneness
oneness seems to separate itself into
amnest and is-ness
amnesty becomes i and is-ness becomes
other consciousness and being
seem to separate i am everything becomes
the belief and the feeling
i am some things and not others
now becomes i am that particular thing i
am some thing it believes and feels i am
the body
a process of selection by i like and i
don't like
i want and i don't want cravings and
aversions
a web of desire and fear is woven likes
and dislikes fragments the seamless
totality of experience
the belief in feeling i am the body
becomes dense
solid sticky and layered
the return from i am something to i am
everything is simply the loosening of
this
dense fabric of self the open space of
consciousness begins to know itself
again
as a welcoming space in which everything
is allowed to pass
as it will when it will where it will
the net of desires and fears is
unstitched
no longer has any power to separate
anything from anything
the body returns to its original
transparency open
available loving and acutely sensitive
beholding onto
nothing the mind is liberated from the
tyranny of a separate self
and becomes clear lively and kind the
beauty and vibrancy
of the world is restored
love it
it is like removing objects from a room
one by one
until only the space of the room remains
mind is further reduced in understanding
and is now realized to be a projection
of consciousness to be made out of
consciousness
the individual person who seemed to be
the experiencer of the dream was in fact
experienced
within the dream
the appearance of the separate entity in
the waking state
is essentially the same as that in the
dream state
again we prioritize the explanation of
this metaphor
in our interview with rupert at the very
beginning
and throughout so go and check that out
the god's brain having a dream
of these creation design realities and
that's why
it's recursive in the sense that we
spend a third of our lives
also sleeping
when you take the first person's
perspective in the dream
state at night you simulate that entire
oneness of a dream as both the first
person experiencer
and the dream
dreamt environment itself and that is
what this is
similarly we simulated out
our environment and we're taking the
first person perspective
and we're all god
this veiling activity this imagining
myself to be a limited entity
is consciousness's own activity its own
creativity
it's really creative we do a good job
with this
time and space appear within it it does
not appear within time and space
reality is one solid seamless
indivisible substance made out of
luminosity transparency knowingness
beingness
consciousness projects the dream world
within itself
through the functions of thinking and
imagining consciousness projects the
waking world within itself
through the functions of sensing and
perceiving as well as thinking and
imagining
in deep sleep there is no projection
and therefore no time or space there is
no world there is simply presence
and that presence is this presence
all experience takes place here a
distant
sound takes place here the chair
on the other side of the room is
perceived here
everywhere is present here the body
is a sensation inside this
here inside presence
everything takes place here inside
consciousness
the idea that experience takes place
there or outside
vanishes
that sugar cube i love that analogy
dissolving in the hot tea
of self-realization
all experience takes place now all
memories of the past
take place now all thoughts about the
future take place
now this now does not last in time
all time lasts in it
this placeless timeless presence is the
transparent
homogeneous substantial ever-present
reality of experience within which and
ultimately as which
the fleeting insubstantial and
intermittent experiences
that we call the body the mind in the
world appear
like waves
is like a three-dimensional mirror in
which everything appears
everything that appears in the mirror of
consciousness
is at the same distance from it and that
is
no distance at all every experience
is presence
the mirror of consciousness is the
screen on which everything
is experienced and at the same time it
is that
which experiences everything
consciousness that is experiencing
itself
as that apparent object the transparent
medium of consciousness
is colored by the appearance of an
object
again transparent consciousness
eternally colored
again ocean
always creatively expressing itself as
waves
transparent consciousness eternally
colored
again consciousness modulating equals
the water in ocean taking shape of
waves
consciousness knows a thing by being
that thing
that is its mode of knowing anything
rather consciousness takes the shape of
the object
of the current experience from moment to
moment
whilst always remaining exactly as it is
as the water in the ocean rises and
swells into the shape of a wave
flows for a while and then falls back
into the ocean without ever for a moment
being anything other than water
so every object every experience arises
within consciousness
takes its unique shape does its unique
thing
and then offers backs its name and form
to the ocean
of presence which abides in and as
itself before taking the shape of the
next
wave
love it rupert
the wave gives water a name and a form
when the wave vanishes only name and
form
vanish water remains as it always
is only names and forms are continually
transformed
one womb many forms wherever we look we
see only the face of god
god sees herself in all things
mind used for the practical purpose of
functioning at the level of the mind
body and world
it is a way of seeing and talking that
enables a certain level of functioning
in the world
and as such it has its legitimate place
it is only when we take such a statement
as a description
of our actual experience as a
description of reality
that the confusion begins
and this is why we talk a lot about
the middle path the middle way with the
goldilocks zone
when you experience non-dual awareness
you
undergo the tantric path of weaving the
self-realization into the social fabric
rather than where you
completely ignore this portion right
here
which is where you no longer even
entertain any of the functioning of the
world
and that would be on going too high
whereas the going too low
is this part where you stay as the egoic
separate entity
investigate consciousness to cleanse
mirror
it is the edifice
of ideas that seems to prevent
consciousness from knowing itself
knowingly
from perceiving itself just as it is the
edifice that prevents the man from
seeing himself in the mirror
the man can deconstruct the edifice
so deconstruct the edifice or another
way to say it is cleanse the mirror
right cleanse the channel
it is the freedom that consciousness has
from moment to moment to create the idea
that it is a separate personal entity
to believe that idea to forget that it
has chosen to believe it
and therefore to consider it a fact to
explore the fact and rediscover that it
is a belief
to stop believing it and to realize
again that it is simply an idea
and is as such one of many possible
modes of being that consciousness
chooses from moment to moment
out of its own freedom
out of our own freedom we're playing the
game of the
egoic separate self
i am that separate entity the sole cause
of psychological suffering
consciousness is freedom itself it is
free to forget and free to remember
we mentioned this earlier this is why
ramana maharshi was often silent when
asked a question
the highest answer to a question about
the nature of reality or the self is
always reality or the self itself
and this cannot be spoken of so he would
just remain
silent
if the absolute truth is spoken by one
who is parroting the truth and thus does
not come from true understanding the
answer will lack
depth and that will be transmitted
and this is profound because about a
year ago or so
i was undergoing a process of kind of
like
awakening but really slowly and i was
trying to explain some of these
metaphors about the sky and the clouds
or about the ocean and the waves
but i couldn't do it even as i was
explaining
it i couldn't do it because i didn't get
it experientially i hadn't
embodied non-dual awareness my egoic
separate self
sugar cube had not dissolved in the hot
tea
of the oceanic infinity of consciousness
and so now one year later i'm very
clearly able to transmit
the direct path teachings because i have
experientially
underwent the satori
and now i am that non-dual awareness
it's so fascinating
so you can tell by the people that you
listen to
this is why we highly recommend people
like rupert spyra
and like bentino massaro and like ramana
maharshi and the sargatuta maharaja and
there's
there's many other shunya murti there's
many other
self-realized
teachers right now that are doing a
great job
so your discernment is key
we are deceiving ourself if we wash a
veneer
of there is only one consciousness over
feelings that i am this body
or am in this body
and we'll get to a graphic that explains
this more in a moment
it could be said that the rational
investigation at the level of beliefs
and ideas is a prelude
to the deeper exploration of the sense
of separation at the level of the body
on the path of discrimination we
discover what we are not
on the path of love we discover what we
are this discovery is a moment by moment
revelation
it cannot be crystallized in words it is
the true
unknowing in which nothing is known but
everything is
embraced
every experience every appearance is a
wave on the ever present ocean of
presence if we look at the waves they
change
from moment to moment if we look at the
water the water itself never changes
this is exactly what we talk about in
chapter 10 on infinity and high level
perception
where you literally have parmenidus who
says
2 500 years ago that the water
itself never changes whereas heraclitus
says ponteray everything flows which is
the waves
they change from moment to moment and
it's the synthesis of those two
that gives you the full realization
the flow of a river always changes shape
but the substance of a river
never disappears and again we have the
screen analogy
experience is like an image on a tv
screen appearances come and go but in
fact the appearance of the image
is nothing but the screen and the screen
does not come and go
this ever present now is colored from
time to time with apparent objectivity
when we have reduced the multiplicity of
things in understanding
to one thing we can further reduce that
one thing
into our self capital s the permanent
background
and substance of all things this
discovery does not make it so but rather
reveals that it has always been so
and this is a recent visual that we
posted on our instagram
again it's the wisdom of digging all the
way to water so approximately 85 percent
of people on the planet live in a state
of multiplicity
aka the egoic separate self and then
there are some people that are seeking
on the spiritual path to get to this
ocean
and some of them have reached a little
water
and that's the oneness and that's about
where i was
about at the beginning of 2020
and throughout until just about
three three weeks ago or so and so about
three weeks ago or so on december 18th
2020 i pierce the veil and so what that
means is the oneness
is very much like a belief about oh it's
all one
and it's a very intellectual and
philosophical belief and it makes sense
but you don't actually pierce the veil
yet because
the piercing of the veil to get to the
self where only about one percent of
people on the planet are is this
oceanic-ness
and that only occurs when you realize
what non-dual awareness truly is when
you really
realize that your sugar cube of the
separate entity
of that ego completely dissolves in the
t of
infinite consciousness and so that is
when
the veil is pierced and you recognize
that that infinite consciousness is
eternal
and that its nature is bliss in peace
and that it is being colored
by experience creative modulations of
the waves of the ocean
and so for me that only happened a
couple weeks ago with my profound satori
and so this analogy here this metaphor
is really strong but you have to dig
all the way to water a lot of people
stop here when they reach a little water
when they get to the intellectualization
of the oneness
and so you have to go all the way to
water follow that seeking impulse like
it's your lifeline
to fully pierce the veil to
self-realization to god realization
if we truly feel that everything and
everyone is an expression of the same
one reality
that we ourselves are we will act
accordingly and will
quite literally behave towards others as
we would behave
towards ourselves whatever the shape of
that action it will come from the
feeling of the essential oneness of all
things
everything is an expression of oneness
ignorance and wisdom
alike
if we think we experience objects we are
not experiencing consciousness knowingly
to experience separate objects is not to
experience consciousness knowingly to
experience consciousness knowingly
is to not experience objects we cannot
claim to be experiencing objects and
consciousness
at the same time maya still dances
but it is a dance of love not seduction
i love that as a result we no longer
believe the divisive dualistic concepts
of the mind we no longer believe in good
and bad as absolute realities
if we see everything as an expression of
one reality
we are taking our stand at a place that
is prior to the mind prior to good and
bad
right and wrong
and that's why rumi has a quote also
that goes
something along the lines of i'll meet
you on the other side
where the transcendent of the duality
of right and wrong is
true benevolent indifference of presence
we expose misunderstandings unsubscribe
from separate self egoic matrix identity
layers
ending of thought reveals this
understanding
then understanding shines during thought
itself
so again the misunderstanding is being
exposed
understanding is revealed by thought not
explained by it
in fact it is the ending of thought that
reveals understanding
revealed when thought comes to an end
later it is realized to be present
during thought itself
reality is beyond the abstract concepts
of the mind
and therefore has no objective
characteristics
the thought that seeks reality comes to
its own limit and plunges into reality
itself it dies
in that which it was seeking and its
dissolution is the revelation of that
ever-present reality
this non-objective experience has an
impact on the body mind
and is usually described in terms of
some sort of release
or expansion the clenched fist
letting go
the experience that it is looking for is
the experience of its own self its own
ever-present reality
which is lying behind and within every
experience
including the experience of seeking
itself
the experience that consciousness is
looking for is prior to the body
in the mind
it knows itself as space during the
presence
and the absence of the house
permeated with the peace of presence
on waking the body mind reappears in
presence
saturated with the peace of deep sleep
exposing the wrong formulations of our
experience
the misunderstandings relieves
consciousness of the relentless search
for itself
in the realm of the body mind and the
world
as soon as consciousness releases itself
in this way it finds that it is always
present
that its own presence is always here
shining and always has been
consciousness sees itself shining within
itself
when it looks back at the old objects
that seem to veil itself from itself
it just sees them shining in and as
itself
separating nothing from nothing
here's a great ramana maharshi quote
that which is not present in deep
dreamless sleep
is not real
so deep sleep is peace in myself
peace consciousness without an object
enables the body and mind to reappear
refreshed in the morning saturated with
the peace from which it arises
the i myself am deep sleep
deep sleep is the experience of
consciousness peace and myself
simultaneously
meditation is like being asleep while
remaining awake
remain knowingly as this consciousness
peace i
every experience of the dreaming and
waking worlds
is only this consciousness piece i
taking the shape of thinking
imagining sensing and perceiving
it is that which takes the shape of
every experience
and that which is the substance the
reality of every experience
i consciousness is that
silence is the background of presence
which is the support and substance of
all appearances
including an absence of sound
aka the silence between the notes
is what makes the music
and that's the oceanic-ness between
the waves
it is an alive open unknowingness that
is free to take
any shape or any position at any moment
in relation to the moment itself
the words are the packaging once the
message
this unknowing openness is delivered or
rather revealed the packaging can be
discarded the words can be forgotten
the teaching remains free of fixed
formulations dogma and fundamentalism
it remains fluid playful enjoyable
unpredictable and ungraspable
it always leaves us in open
unknowingness this open unknowingness is
what we
are and that's why the direct path is
such a profound teaching compared to the
dogman fundamentalism
of any of the old traditions that have
kept
us religiously enslaved to some sort of
a deity that is exterior
the kingdom of god is within you
luke 17 21
and leo tolstoy it returns the veiled
unknowingness to an open unknowingness
that is silent
empty free luminous transparent and
unlimited
ready at any moment to take the shape of
just this
again it's infinite exploration
just be now
love the unfolding journey
oceanicness infinitely
modulating creatively as waves
ride at the peak of the wave
at the peak of the now just be
in that unfolding
there is only consciousness being this
is known as i
and also as happiness love peace beauty
and understanding
what more meaning and purpose than that
could there possibly be
the end of the desire reveals the
underlying
ever-present happiness
the agitation called seeking veils the
inherent happiness and understanding
happiness is the particular name
consciousness gives itself when it
experiences itself
at the end of a desire understanding
is the particular name consciousness
gives itself when it experiences itself
at the end of a thought
happiness and understanding are the
experience of consciousness
recognizing itself at the end of that
search
presence is never lost and never found
it is ever
present the activities of forgetting
searching and finding are all equally
modes of its own being
in which it is always only experiencing
itself in changing names and forms
the oceanic presence
is ever present and all of the
activities of the waves of forgetting
searching and finding are equally modes
of creative expression
of its being and those are all just
changing names and forms
we've been doing it we're gonna continue
doing it
it's the nature of reality wake up to it
the end of the desire is the end of the
mind's agitation
this agitation is nothing other than
consciousness thinking and feeling
that the happiness and peace that are
inherent in itself are not present and
as a result
searching for them elsewhere
it had just veiled itself with desire
with the thought
and feeling i need something else in
order to be happy
happiness is not an experience that
consciousness has
it is what consciousness is this is why
joy is said to be causeless
actually rupert taught me during our
interview he says
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
happiness like beauty and love is
absolute
not relative they are all inherent in
consciousness
they do not change or disappear
peace is beyond the mind joy is uncaused
beauty has no form love is unconditional
and understanding knows no
object there is peace
joy beauty love and understanding and
all these are experiences of the
transparent
luminous empty knowingness of presence
beautiful all unhappy states are only
this consciousness
forgetting itself
the ultimate cause of suffering is
ignorance of our true nature
that is the ignoring of our true nature
the ignoring of consciousness
where is suffering in deep sleep it is
non-existent
deep sleep and the present moment share
much in common
the past and the future have much in
common with the dream
state suffering by definition requires
the presence of a separate
entity for its existence however that
separate entity is itself
non-existent imaginary
the mind cannot represent that which has
no objective qualities
so when it goes towards consciousness
it collapses it just cannot go
there and that's the sugar cube
melting in the hot tea
of infinite consciousness an analogy is
so good
the value of seeking is that as long as
it is taken
all the way back to its source aka drill
all the way to water dig all the way to
water
it brings itself to its own limit and
dissolves there
that into which it dissolves is that for
which
it was seeking
you are that which you seek or
as saint francis of assisi said that
that which is
we are seeking that which is
looking
it's been said so many times by so many
of the greats so many different ways
just dig all the way to water
consciousness that dissolves the seeking
thought
just as water dissolves a sugar cube
it is in the dissolution of thinking
that consciousness
tastes itself seeking never finds
what it is looking for it is dissolved
in it
the experience of consciousness
recognizing itself that brings about the
end of seeking
the mind does not find understanding it
dies
in it piercing the veil equals ego
and seeking dissolution
that sugar cube analogy is just so damn
good
piercing the veil is the ego
and seeking dissolving in the hot
tea of infinite consciousness so
beautiful
allow that understanding to express
itself naturally it will
condition our life in just the same way
that our previous understanding
conditioned our life effortlessly
individual means undivided individuality
is the unique expression of the
undivided
whole love that
flourish rather than diminish when we
are relieved of the straitjacket of
ignorance
when we stop ignoring ourself complete
openness sensitivity vulnerability and
availability
consciousness is absolute freedom we
allow this freedom to express itself
as it will how it will where it will and
when it will
the attitude of inner freedom that is
the hallmark of
understanding and this attitude of inner
freedom uses
all possible means of expression and
communication
so inner freedom does not necessarily
mean
being a silent monk so not always but
sometimes
it takes on a myriad of unique
expressions so you can be
have inner freedom and be extremely
creative and be extremely expressive
in myriad ways
we no longer escape these feelings we
have the courage to face them
we do not do anything with them or to
them
and by the same token we do not deny
avoid or suppress
them these all-consuming feelings lose
their bite they are neutralized not
because we have done anything to them
but simply because they have been seen
for what they
are
they are currents rippling through the
ocean of our self
love and accept your cloud modulations
and this can also be love and accept
your wave modulations
and then recognize yourself as the sky
slash
ocean and then eternal
bliss peace colored by experience
so the sky or ocean is the eternal bliss
piece
that is colored by the experience of
loving and accepting these cloud slash
wave modulations
it is the permanence of the screen
that is indicated by the apparent
continuity of the traveling dot
there is in fact no traveling dot as
einstein said the separate self is an
optical delusion in consciousness
consciousness is the most intimate thing
we know the intimacy that we seek and
love in relationships is precisely this
intimacy of our own self
consciousness is to myself what
existence or being
is to the world i is consciousness
am is being the experience of i am is
the most intimate and familiar
experience we know
period it is the experience of the
oneness of consciousness and being
when this oneness divides itself into a
body and a world it veils itself from
itself
and causes psychological suffering
every object appears within
consciousness and its existence cannot
be separated from the presence of
consciousness
consciousness is the fundamental reality
of the world that consciousness and
being
are one and you have this i am
so consciousness or chit in being in
existence
sat sat chit ananda
existence consciousness bliss
consciousness is naturally one with all
things it is one with the totality of
experience
at times consciousness contracts itself
shrinks itself into a body
and this self-contraction requires
constant maintenance the
self-contraction gradually unwinds
and consciousness returns to its natural
condition again
the clenched fist
relaxing desiring and fearing are two of
the main ways that consciousness
maintains
its self-contraction as an apparent
separate entity
however as consciousness becomes more
and more accustomed
to abiding in and as itself as it no
longer pretends to be a separate entity
to go out of itself in search of itself
this natural abidance in and as itself
becomes normal and ordinary
the self-contraction which once seemed
to be so normal and ordinary
that now becomes extraordinary the real
blasphemy is to think i am a separate
entity
with that thought consciousness denies
its own unlimited universal sovereignty
it surrenders its freedom it is its
freedom to do so
out of this freedom consciousness
projects the mind the body in the world
through the faculties of thinking
imagining sensing and perceiving
there is nothing wrong with the
projection of a separate entity
it is essential for many aspects of life
it is only the exclusive
identification with it that is
problematic
it sees all things in and as itself
that's it folks
so profoundly important also check out
the
other publications by rupert
again you can find all of these
the art of peace and happiness the
intimacy of all experience sayings
on the essence of non-duality 30
meditations
on the essence of non-duality the light
of pure knowing the ashes of love and
presence volume one and two
go and find all of those on rupert's
website uh the links in the bio below
again this ending
so we see all things in and as
ourselves everything is
us the universal one
the infinite consciousness
again go and check out more by rupert um
also this is his website
it's also in the bio below
rupertspyro.com go check that out
he also is uh a great ceramic
artist you can go see that there too
again the essence of
the essence of this is so simple
guys
the transparency of things simply put
is the direct path to
your consciousness and your awareness to
become
really awake
to the oceanic infinity
in eternity of that consciousness and of
that awareness that is
shared
reality and consciousness are one
the spiritual and the physical are one
our eternal
our nature is bliss and peace
and that awareness is eternally being
colored
by the modulations of the oceanic
waves or the
clouds in the sky again the analogies
and the metaphors that rupert uses are
so poignant
they're salient they're paramount in
understanding this
again the ocean the infinite
consciousness
and the waves are the modulations of
experience
similarly the sky is the infinite
consciousness
and the clouds are the modulations of
experience
again the sugar cube
as soon as the contraction
of the egoic separate self
follows the seeking impulse
it turns on itself and the ego with the
separate self
and the mind dissolve as the sugar cube
in the t of infinite consciousness
it's that simple the transparency of
things contemplating the nature of
experience by rupert spyra
check it out the links in the bio below
i hope you had a lot of value
come from this exegesis and we drew
out so much of the salience here
and i hope it was very valuable for you
and
i hope that go back through the video
pause it
as needed write down the key points with
your own exegesis of the most salient
things
and then practice them to get to that
non-dual awareness that we're talking
about of the ocean of the sky
and realize it as the eternal fireworks
the eternal artistic modulation of
infinity
recognize that and you got it
and re-baseline to that keep that light
bulb on
and then buy the book yourself buy
rupert's books
and go through the process of exegesis
yourself that will
absolutely help you in your process so
do that too the links are in the bio
below
and go and watch his youtube channel
watch his youtube channel
he has a lot of great videos on there
unpacking
non-duality again one of the world's
best teachers of non-duality
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe if you haven't yet share the
video with other people
let's get more of these teachings of
non-duality out around the world
and let me know how you feel in the
comments below i'd love to hear from you
where are you adding your
self-realization of nondual awareness
and i'll do my best to get in there and
comment back
as much as i can and i love you
thank you very much for tuning in we
love you rupert spyra thank you so much
i love you a lot
and i'm very grateful for your entire
team as well that's helping
the communication of all of the
perennial
non-dual wisdom so it's been an honor
working with you and i look forward to
continue working with you
this is awesome so so awesome
we'll be doing more um videos like this
soon we have some more of rupert's books
coming we have more of
david hawkins coming and there's a lot
of other
epic people that we have lined up and
you can go watch the universal one video
with walter russell that we just did as
well
because there's a lot of synergy between
the non-dual spiritual teachings that
rupert's sharing here as well as what
people like walter russell and nicola
tesla
are sharing as well with their synthesis
of metaphysics and science so
love you tons thanks for tuning in we'll
see you soon
thank you peace
you